[Music]
I'm Doug bourgeois I'm a managing
director in Deloitte's government and
public services consulting practice and
I'm also the lead alliance partner for
our relationship with Google in the
government industry sector a couple of
my colleagues will be joining me on
stage in just a few minutes
Shaun Conlon who is a principal in our
analytics and cognitive government
public services practice he's gonna
focus on the persona today of a data
scientist merican hawa is a medical
doctor and also managing director in our
life sciences and healthcare practice
and she's gonna address the situation
from a practitioners perspective so
before we get into the subject of today
the opioid epidemic and a solution to
help look at it a little differently I'd
like to spend a few minutes talking
about our relationship with Google and
why it's so important actually I'm gonna
I'm gonna focus on a few a few key words
here around the relationship three to be
specific first is transformation
Deloitte is really all about
transformation we're about
transformation for our clients we help
our clients plan for and execute broad
transformation initiatives to drive
their strategic agendas forward and and
leverage innovation in the process
Google technologies I'm sure you're all
aware because you're here Google
technologies are transformative they
often form the catalyst of broad
transformation and innovation for our
clients and that's one of the reasons
why joining together and joining forces
Deloitte and Google is so powerful so
more specifically you know some of the
things that that Deloitte brings we wrap
our services around Google's technology
and Google services and we address
things like program management for
example we bring broad experience and
proven methods to help our clients plan
and execute successful transformation
programs
we also address project management
expertise both the mechanics of project
management but also bringing domain
experts in our clients mission areas and
also experts in the technologies at hand
around Google that we bring to those
those projects and and execute from a
project standpoint successfully as well
in addition to that as you can imagine
with a focus on transformation change
management is potentially a substantial
issue for our clients so we we bring
again experienced practitioners and
proven methods to help our clients plan
for and manage the organizational change
that comes to light invariably when
you're driving transformation for them
and then finally and this is an area
we've really made substantial
investments from a firm standpoint over
the last several years is the technology
engineering is that we essentially
provide scale to Google engineering in
Google technology by bringing several
thousand trained Google engineers to the
table as well one quick note on our on
our capability so the second word if the
first word was transformation the second
word is capable we are very proud about
the announcement earlier this week that
for the second consecutive year Deloitte
was named Google's global systems
integrator alliance partner of the year
and that is of course the result of you
know substantial amount of investment
it's the abstention amount of commitment
by a tremendous group of leaders and
individuals from a broad scale
perspective and I think it's primarily
indicative of both the breadth you know
its global and it is spans all
industries as well and the depth as I
mentioned you know addressing strategy
through architecture engineering and
even into operations so it's indicative
of our breath and our depth and you know
some indicators of that of course we
have a premier partner status with
Google cloud we go to market around key
cloud solutions like s AP and Salesforce
and then not the least of which some of
our specializations and relevant to
today's conversation machine learning
and cloud migration specializations as
well so the third word if the first word
was transformation and the second word
was capable the third word is solutions
from a go-to-market standpoint we've
really focused on developing solutions
using Google Cloud in Google
technologies that are addressing some of
the broader kind of impactful challenges
that our clients face every day to drive
the transformation of their own mission
and their own objectives so the first
I'm not going to go through all of these
but a couple that are worth mentioning
is the analytics solutions with mission
graph it's primarily a platform and it's
a platform that ingests data across
disparate data sources looks for
relationships among that data and then
it has some really strong and powerful
visualization capabilities to help us
position our clients to gain substantial
insights into the information that they
that they're looking at and that is
actually the platform that was used to
develop the opioid 360 solution that
we're gonna go through here in just a
few minutes
second fraud detection of course I'm in
the government practice and my
colleagues as well but if you're if it
involves money changing hands or
transactions fraud is potentially an
issue broadly so we're addressing that
again with a platform approach bringing
multiple solutions to address fraud
detection from a variety of perspectives
to the market and then finally IOT IOT
is a hot topic these days but we see it
as very much a convergence of cloud of
analytics and IOT at the edge and we've
got some really interesting solutions
out in the market that we've been able
to partner with Google to develop and
and help our clients look at some some
of their new challenges out at the edge
of their of their networks of course
security comes into play there as well
so again transformational capable
and a solution focus and then of course
opioid 360 is the the area of focus for
today's discussion so in just a few
minutes my colleagues are going to come
up on stage and and start to maybe
enlighten us a little bit around
thinking around this particular
challenge but first what we're going to
do is we're going to show a quick very
brief video to kind of set the stage for
the way we're looking at the problem
the opioid epidemic is like nothing
we've seen each day it claims an average
of 130 lives in the US alone its impact
can be felt across families and
communities and it is being fought by
first responders law enforcement and
health care providers but its complexity
means no one group is able to offer a
complete solution to combat the opioid
epidemic those at the front line must be
swift deliberate and collaborative they
need to intervene early on to help focus
resources and protect lives they need to
get to the future faster that's why in
collaboration with Google and data
stacks Deloitte has created an analytic
solution for the people and
organizations responding to this
challenge opioid 360 is sophisticated
and flexible synthesizing de-identified
data from disparate and siloed sources
and providing insight into the crisis
like never before
and it leverages our deep experience
with AI and predictive modeling helping
your organization take the right action
at the right time imagine those on the
front line being able to dial into the
needs of specific populations imagine
the risk of addiction mapped against
barriers to treatment such as housing
insecurity unreliable transportation or
lack of insurance imagine all of this
powered by a dedication to privacy and
security and the empathetic knowledge
that people are more than datasets
people require tailored interventions
ones that match their medical needs and
address any barriers to care like
transportation assistance for Chris so
he can get to his local treatment
facility where the support Maria needs
to keep her family of four together
while she receives treatment and
information for Alex's medical provider
so he can make the best choice about how
to manage Alex's back pain we don't have
one opioid epidemic but many striking in
tandem with opioid 360 we gain
much-needed visibility it's predictive
models help identify at-risk populations
and treatment barriers earlier in the
life side
leading to timely proven interventions
and its flexibility makes it a viable
tool for each of the multiple
organizations trying to solve this
complex costly an interconnected problem
a future with lower grades of opioid
misuse can start today it's time for
opioid 360
[Music]
good afternoon many of you in this room
fall into one of two communities one of
the communities is made up of health
practitioners policymakers scientists
and others who operate on the frontline
of the opiate response and for all of
those in that community thank you
there's a second community that's made
up of the diet data scientists and the
data scientists are operating they are
driving across and making a difference
in our economy and in our society and
the time is right for that community to
have a big impact in helping with the
opiate crisis
My partner Mira and I are going to share
with you today and a solution an
innovative solution called PO pewds 360
it is a it holds the promise of
potentially being that solution from the
data science community that can be make
a big difference for those on the front
line the the purpose of I'm sorry the
the way we're going to structure today's
conversation is just that a dialogue
between those two communities I am going
to be the voice of the data science
community and Mira is going to be the
voice of the first responders or the the
front sorry pro-life frontline sorry the
frontline community myself I am Sean
Conlon I am a principal and Deloitte
Consulting I bring AI solutions to
government organizations the
organization I'm a leader in has about a
thousand data scientists that's about
10% of our government of our national
data scientists Mira who I'm going to
introduce will introduce herself in just
a minute but the opioid salute
that we're bringing forward is an
innovative solution that brings AI and
large datasets together and holds
tremendous promise we're excited to
share that with you
Mira could you introduce yourself and
offer perspective on the opiates crisis
sure Thank You Sean
everybody it's a pleasure to be here
with you this afternoon my name is Mira
and taua I'm an emergency medicine
physician and I practiced on the
frontlines of inner-city emergency
departments from us 20 years I have
physically laid hands on 80,000 patients
not including those I treated in a
warzone while I was in Iraq I've seen
every aspect of the opiate situation
from point of injury acute injury to
heroin overdoses to death in my
emergency department and let me tell you
what there's nothing that's more painful
than trying to tell somebody at 3:00 in
the morning who's begging begging and
crying for 350 milligrams of Demerol
that they can't have it because you know
that they're on the road to addiction
and it's a very very difficult and
complicated disease to treat from a
provider perspective so I'm gonna speak
to you today as a provider I left
clinical medicine after 18 years of
practice because of the promise of
Technology having an ability to truly
transform the way we deliver care and in
an industry where our data is growing at
the rate of petabytes per year petabytes
per year right we on the frontlines
taking care of patients our data poor
imagine that irony right how do you
solve that problem so what I would
really love for technology to do for me
and all of my colleagues that take care
of patients day in and day out is make
us smarter help me take care of my
patients better help me do it more
efficiently and more effectively so that
they don't keep bouncing back to the
emergency department
and in our nation's emergency
departments when I started practicing we
had under a hundred million visits a
year currently in the nation's emergency
departments that growth to emergency
departments has increased unfettered at
the rate of 8 to 12 percent per year for
the last 25 years why is that people
don't have primary care have no way to
go to get care they can't be seen on a
routine basis virtual health isn't
deployed they don't have access they
don't have transportation they don't
money to get there and we know that when
they do this morbidity and mortality
increases in a manner that is documented
in peer-reviewed literature and we'll
share some of that with you later today
so with that you know we can I think the
best way of putting this opioid use
disorder into perspective is in the time
that we are all sitting in this room
today for Souls will die for people will
die while we're sitting here in this
room and that's really tragic and
especially when these deaths are 100%
preventable okay so we wanted to build a
tool that was able to move the needle to
the left right that really helped us
identify those patients who are at risk
so that you could offer them better
treatments and better interventions and
with that I'm gonna turn it back over to
you Sean great so thanks Mara so from a
data science community perspective why
don't we start unpacking what are the
kinds of questions what kinds of
predictions what would be helpful to you
in the frontline response community that
would be helpful yeah sure so you know
imagine you're in an emergency
department because easy for me to do and
you get two people who both come in with
back pain both of them have been
prescribed t threes percocet
flexeril or whatever the cocktail dujour
is that they got and they're both there
it's impossible for me to know who's
gonna be at higher risk of addiction
right because I'm treating acute pain at
a point in time but that's also the best
time for me to intervene it may be the
only time they see medical care all
right so if we can figure out who is at
higher risk I could then put my case
managers in I could get them to follow
up I could do whatever I had to do to
get systems in place to get them in care
so that would be the first question all
right so we guess the first one right
who's at risk okay yeah and you know I
think the next question is can we turn
down the volume on me a little bit I'm
sorry I'm hearing a lot of reverb thank
you is really understanding what the
barriers to treatment are so medical
treatment for opiate addiction does work
it is very effective there is some
recidivism and that is because when you
are addicted to opiates you really have
changes going on in your neuronal
pathways in your brain right so there is
a rewiring of your brain that does occur
so the medication treatment protocols
have to actually bring you back and only
about two people out of ten that
actually would benefit from medical
treatment are actually receiving that
today so it would be great to know what
the barriers to people getting that
treatment are so we guessed right on the
second one - but let me let's just
emphasize that for a minute so
nationally for those into it so the
scientific community has done an amazing
job we have medical treatment that can
help those who are addicted yeah
absolutely effective the evidence is in
the evidence is in that's probably the
only ray of sunshine in this whole mess
but as a nation think about this of all
of those who need to be on medical
treatment and it works only two out of
ten individuals are getting access to
that and as a nation what are those
barriers keeping people from getting
access to that treatment the country is
spending a fortune
treatments but people are not getting
there and unpacking that and
understanding what that is and how AI
and analytics and data can help the
decision makers better manage that is an
important issue for the nation
absolutely absolutely
and I think to better understand this it
would really be good to know what kinds
of interventions now typically when you
hear a doctor say intervention you're
thinking Oh some kind of procedure you
know a doctor thing but not really right
we do know at this point that social
determinants of health okay are 80% of
the equation when it comes to our own
health and determining how healthy we
are and when you think about social
determinants think about getting good
sleep
exercise diet and how you live where you
live who you're surrounded by okay these
are all social determinants of health so
understanding what the interventions are
we're actually talking about Human
Services interventions not medical
treatments so I look at those as
different things so again what are some
of the so let me just say back what I
heard there so there's medical treatment
and that's not what we're talking about
with opioid 360 but a very big
influencer on whether somebody gets
healthy or not or is successful against
the addiction is whether or not they
have the right social services around
them social determinants of health
absolutely so there is increasing
peer-reviewed literature you know in
many of the leading journals about how
those social determinants actually
improve or decrease our health okay so
from a data science community
perspective to those on the front line
if we can help you better understand
really in the life cycle who's at
elevated risk of opioid use disorder if
we can help you identify at the
individual level what the barriers to
treatment are and then if we can help
make suggestions of what our optimal
interventions for individuals that would
be helpful it would be really helpful if
you
move the leet needle to the left and get
those people who are at highest risk
right finding that needle in a haystack
okay and get them into care programs
before they get addicted to the point
where they end up seeing me from their
heroin overdose that'd be really great
excellent
okay so let's unpack opioid 360 and talk
about first the data before we get into
the details of the data let's level set
on this first and foremost personal
identified information is protected here
okay we D identify the data and then we
bring it together in opioid 360 okay
there are three major areas of data that
are fed into this system and this is
very large data sets the primary users
of it currently and probably for the for
the foreseeable near-term future our
government state governments in
particular and if you think about a
state government this is the first data
set the public sector data you've got
three major areas of the state
government that are dealing with this
opioid crisis you've got the Health the
Human Services and the law enforcement
parts of the state government if you
peel that back that's 25 or 30 different
data sets typically if you go from state
to state and being able to bring that
data together de-identified because keep
in mind you have see--just laws and
HIPPA laws and all sorts of complex
legal requirements so you D identify the
data where it sits and then you bring it
together and you can link the
de-identified data together and the
purpose of opiate 360 is not at that
individual level per se but it's more to
be able to look at millions of examples
over 10 20 years and look for patterns
in those data sets that are strongly
indicative of elevate those three
questions elevated risk and what's
worked what's what interventions have
been successful for people who fit into
that persona and which ones have not
been so you can more intelligently make
decisions around resource allocations
okay
that's the first of the three kinds of
data the second one is what's called a
lifestyle data set
Mira talked about social determinants of
health so there is publicly accessible
data that gives indications of
particular things on lifestyle we'll
look at this in just a minute but that's
an important data set and then there's a
third one that through our partnership
with Google a very important data set
that's from Google Analytics and there's
some very interesting research one of
the most recent ones was in a Scientific
American article from December that
shows a positive correlation between
certain Google data being an early
indicator of what becomes opiate use or
even opiate related death and it's
through the analytics engine we
aggregated up to a geography footprint
PII is strictly protected just as into
the other data sets okay so that's the
data that we bring in one thing I
emphasize too and then I'll pull you
back in Mira is we crafted this data
very carefully one of the biggest
problems that we've heard from those on
the front line is that the data tends to
be very old relatively speaking yes when
you're looking at public sector data
typically claims data is gonna be aged
anywhere from 60 to 90 days or more
edie visit data for those registries you
can think about aging of the data all
the way up to about 180 days PDMPs or
prescription drug monitoring programs
could have anywhere from a 30 to 90 day
lag as well right so as you're trying to
identify and predictably identify who
these patients are what we really need
is real-time data right something that
would either leveraging the local health
data exchange for the medical piece but
again keep in mind the medical data is
only 20% of the story the social
determinants and the lifestyle data you
talked about that's the 80% of the story
that I hope you're gonna tell us moves a
needle exactly so we the Google data is
the most the most current data the
lifestyle data is
updated monthly so that's a zero to 30
data set and then you've got the public
sector data that is after 30 days so now
you have a complete continuum of timely
data that the community just doesn't
have today so that harnessed and brought
together in an integrated fashion is
very important maybe an example would be
helpful so imagine that we'd looked at
millions of these cases over many many
years and we had extracted clusters or
personas that were indicative of groups
that were relatively safe and ones that
are very danger that are very much at
risk of developing addiction okay now
we're going to compare two groups and
we're going to start with just the
medical data what Mira was talking about
and this is the data that our frontline
practitioners typically deal with today
this is what they're what they were left
with and each of the these populations
you've got individuals who had a back
pain they have been in rehab for 3 to 6
months they were put onto an opiate
prescription and the question is what's
the likelihood that an individual in
either of those personas would develop
an addiction ok we're not talking the
individual but what is the tendency a
good analogy is when we buy on Amazon
they make suggestions they say if you
buy this you might want to buy this if
you're in one of those personas it's not
deterministic but there's an indication
that you may be at much higher risk than
somebody else that you would develop an
addiction okay yeah and Sean this is
actually what I was talking about before
right when you've got two patients who
show up they both have low back pain
they've both been on similar meds you
have no way of knowing at the
point-of-care who's that higher risk of
addiction even if one of them took an
ambulance to come see you at 3 in the
morning because their back is spasming
right I mean we just have no way of
knowing so so why don't you show us what
this lifestyle data does all right so
let's take a closer look at persona a
okay we're gonna pull in lifestyle and
we're gonna pull in financial
information so you know financials
pretty interesting I mean it turns out
that one-third of all bankruptcies in
the United States are due to medical
costs and there is an absolute
correlation between your overall health
and your financial status and not only
that there is now starting to become a
socio-economic divide for those people
in certain populations whose life span
has actually decreased okay in the
United States our lifespans are
decreasing based on your socioeconomic
status now that's appalling in this
nation okay we are the richest nation on
earth and we have never ever been in the
top ten
Oh acd countries in terms of delivering
care we've never even made it to the top
twenty frankly we never made it to the
top thirty when I started looking at the
data submitted by the World Health
Organization
we were about number in the 80s now
we're somewhere in the 40s so as you
start understanding how the financial
aspects really impact overall health I
think it's critical people don't look at
this and they don't know about it thank
you so people in persona a tend to be
married they tend to have kids they tend
to own their home they tend to eat
healthy they start exercise pretty
quickly after they've there for example
into this scenario they'd be back
exercising they have short commutes they
have strong financial indicators good
financial stability and they live in
economically growing areas okay and if
you look at the neighborhood or the
geographic area where they are they tend
to be in areas where the the Google data
indicates that there's a lot of activity
that correlates to high risk opiate
abuse okay now if we look at persona b2
very different picture okay this people
in this persona tend to again it's not
deterministic but they tend to have a
high rate of divorce they tend to have
unhealthy eating habits long commutes
they don't exercise there's a lot of
bankruptcy and financial distress in
this area and they tend to live in areas
that are not economically stable are
growing and the if you look at the
geographic footprint from the Google
data you can't go to PII but in that
general area it tends to have a high
activity around high-risk search terms
that correlate with oh you dopey ad use
disorder okay now if we revisit the I'm
sorry the predictive models when we
started here based just on the health
data they predicted 10 to 15% chance and
they are both about the same prediction
now with this new data we revisit it
persona a actually dropped significantly
and persona B individuals in that group
went up fourfold massive increase and
this is actually shows up in the data it
very much correlates in the data and the
machine learning predictive models show
that let me just give you a very brief
anecdote if I can I'd like to share one
as well yeah why don't you share and
then I'll share a war story with folks
love war stories yep um you know I think
that providers might ask you well how is
Google data gonna help me be a better
doctor right and my answer to them quite
frankly is the following is you look at
these lifestyle data this is based on
millions of people all right as you look
at drugs that are going through clinical
trial okay you're lucky to get a sample
size of 10,000 patients like that's an
awesome trial all right most of these
sample sizes for FDA trials are five
eight thousand patients this is millions
of patients right so as we think about
is this data
statistically significant alright I mean
we haven't done a chi-square regression
analysis to actually answer that
question but you could intuitively gut
understand that the sample size is
probably going to be very impactful and
I'm excited about the kinds of studies
that we could do based on this data and
showing how it really can help us
determine outcomes excellent
I'd like to draw your attention to the
predictions so there was an interesting
set of work done for the state in the
Midwest for their Medicaid population
and we we were given well over a million
records that went back over ten years
the question was build a predictive AI
model they can identify within that
population who was at elevated risk of
opioid use disorder that was the
question so we built the machine
learning model and there was and when we
brought the results for the client
shared with us that they had actually
built their own predictive model and
they wanted to compare the two so he
said great let's compare them they used
a fundamentally different approach they
had used a rules-based approach it had
hundreds of rules that were from experts
like Mira that said things like if
somebody goes more than 30 miles to get
an opiate prescription filled at a
pharmacy that's a risk factor if they've
got more than one doctor that gives them
an opiate prescription that's a risk
factor and they had hundreds of rules
they had developed over years okay and
we use the machine learning model that
just looked at the data but it had a
massive data set to go train off of
their predictive model identified 15
percent of the target population those
who are at elevated risk of opioid abuse
ours are identified 85 percent they had
a 50 percent error rate we had a 10
percent error rate and probably most
importantly there's took about nine
months of run time for a given
individual from the time they first
started their opiate prescription until
the system had enough data to make a
prediction ours could do it in four to
five months half that time and we've
already got models in the works that are
going to pull that up much shorter an
early prediction early intervention
early identification is the key to
success here and it's showing up in the
data it's showing up in the models
I just you know just for the audience
this is really only showing those
personas that are impacted by medical
prescription as their start to opiates
we know there's another persona right
which is through illegal means
getting heroin IV fentanyl stuff like
that on the street so that's a whole
other way to evaluate risk and we've
actually made progress on that that is a
difficult problem but instead of one
clean area where you can trace it
through the prescriptions through the
doctors there about eight to nine
different variables that can be analyzed
to identify those at-risk populations
and basically be a surrogate for the
data that's in the clean prescription
data set
so why don't we take a look and share
some specific examples okay some actual
use cases
Emira this one is an example of a
statewide policy executive think
Medicaid policy executive who's looking
across an entire state population and to
tee this up because we have this
lifestyle data for demo or for example
purposes what you're about to see here
didn't have the benefit of the state
data and it didn't have the benefit of
the Google Analytics data there's just a
lifestyle data so what we did is we
pulled the data down on seven point
seven million people who live in a
southeast state okay it's all the PII is
stripped out there's just random numbers
you'll see that here in a minute but
we've got lifestyle data on seven point
seven million people so in this one
screen you're interacting with that
complexity okay then on top of that we
apply predictive AI models in a series
of them so if you go across the top
there one of the things we said is for
every one of them we put our score on
what's the likelihood of being at
elevated risk of opioid use disorder and
you'll see they're about one hundred and
forty thousand individuals kind of
depends on where you put the tear line
of what's high risk but it identified
that they're about 2.2 million who are
at high risk of uninsured being
uninsured this is not our medic
expansion state and that the state
confirmed that that's probably about
right when you integrate it with the
state data that number gets dialed in
quite tightly although they even
struggle with that number and then on
the left hand side I'm not going to ask
you to actually read it but they're a
series of filters that we can apply so
Mira for example one of the high-risk
populations and I know you had to deal
with it in the emergency room is what if
we could look across seven point seven
million and identify based on generic
individuals so the PII is protected
pregnant likely at high risk of opiate
addiction uninsured housing and security
and they have children at home that's a
very high-risk population well it's it's
even worse than that right because a
pregnant mom is gonna give birth to an
addicted baby and that baby will be
premature and that baby will spend on
average 45 days in the neonatal
intensive care unit that baby will have
IVs and monitors will likely be
intubated and that baby will go through
withdrawal that tiny little neonate will
with charl in front of your eyes and
it's terrible and these babies cost
about half a million dollars to make it
through that NICU alive and they don't
all make it out alive right so this is a
really huge problem when we're talking
about collateral damage from opiate
addiction I mean you know these our
youngest youngest Souls coming into this
world and if you could move the needle
to the left and not have that pregnant
mom get addicted and not have her give
birth to an addicted baby you'd actually
be saving lives that's a good reminder
that this stuff matters
it does matter absolutely we're not just
talking data we're talking lives so what
we just did there this is we actually
applied all those filters depends where
you put high risk we did six out of a
hundred scale where a hundred is
greenly high risk of addiction this is
60 and above and they're 5,000
individuals in this state that were
identified fitting what we just talked
about if you move it up to 90 so 90 out
of 100 the number of reduces down to
about 500 but that's still 500 and by
weight this is data from the last 30
days
so that's 500 people who fit that
criteria that you can see by the map
which counties they live and where the
densities are we also in the upper right
corner I again it's hard to see in a
room like this but for each of those
individuals again it's the PII is
protected we take we use data to take a
guess of what are the barriers to
treatment that individual is up against
okay and then based on that we aggregate
it so we can look across the 500 or the
5,000 individuals and aggregate that up
for the policy decision maker and they
can say if I pulled these policy levers
in these particular geography in
geographies how am I going to how many
people can I help and I've got limited
resources and how do I get those out
there and get the the most benefit for
society and for these individuals and
this is data they've and capability and
predictions they've never had access to
before
one last thing Mira if we took away the
filters that we just put there and we
just said let's look across the entire
seven point seven million and we said
who's at 90 and above very high risk of
addiction for whatever reason it comes
out to about eighteen thousand
individuals okay and now if you look
down at the bottom there it's a little
hard to see again on this screen but
when we aggregate what are those
barriers to treatment what you find is
they're about 10% again this is with
data from the last 30 days about 10%
would benefit from a HUD housing credit
because their main barrier to treatment
is that they have housing insecurity and
about forty percent would benefit from
Medicaid expansion they just don't have
insurance but otherwise there seems to
be reasonable stability in their life
okay this is and those barriers to
treatment that's where a lot of the
action is in the market place to study
that but these are the kinds of tools
that the people on the front line can be
given to start studying that problem and
see what works and what doesn't
given a particular barrier so you know
there's actually peer-reviewed data that
shows that transportation is actually a
barrier to treatment and in fact dr.
Harold Thomas is a surgeon in the Bronx
did a study on breast cancer individuals
over a 10-year period and started the
patient navigation Institute as a result
of that and was able to successfully
demonstrate that there is a 60% 6-0
percent increase in morbidity and
mortality when something as simple as I
don't have a ride to get to the doctor
right so what's really interesting as a
result of this is that Medicare has now
improved lyft and uber for patients to
get to their appointments anthem Cigna
Humana are all allowing for people who
fit a certain category to be able to
actually get transportation to get there
so and there was an interesting study
done about you're much more likely to
live if you get taken over to the
emergency department then if you take an
ambulance so just keep that in mind
except you want to go to the ER call it
over unless you're having a heart attack
then then call your local ambulance but
pretty interesting so transportation you
wouldn't think it's a big deal but it is
a pretty big deal that example we just
went through is more up at the policy
level a different persona for a user for
this kind of a capability would be more
at the caseworker level now we said all
the PII is protected and you're actually
going to see what it to the extent you
can see it on the screen the guys still
here me I just took my mic we're good
it's still genericized but at the
caseworker level if you think a Medicaid
shop or
Human Services of Child Services using
this kind of capability to that's more
of a caseworker use case where they've
got control of the data they're using
PII today so they could use it just on
their limited data and what you're
looking at here is the center nodes are
patients and it's a patient you're we're
looking at patients doctors everybody in
the ecosystem to entities pharmacies
treatment facilities these are the
high-risk ones in it somebody's area of
responsibility so at a glance you
immediately see where the risk factors
are the scoring is based on the outputs
of predictive AI models okay and now
this is a 360 view hence the name of a
patient patient 400 it's real data well
its patient 400 has a red halo around
her or him and that is indicative that
the predictive score says they're at
high risk of addiction they've got
doctors associate them with them they've
got lifestyle information associated
with them you can see them appearing and
they're receiving food stamps and
financial counseling the power of this
is that we talked about Health Human
Services and law enforcement data when
that starts getting integrated you can
now do this network analysis to see
connections I can see how much is being
spent on individual in the health area
but also their Human Services area and
in law enforcement in not only them but
their dependents so we can start
connecting this data up I said that
we're using AI to connect the data you
could never never connect this kind of
data up if you had to do it manually but
using some machine learning models was
one of the big breakthroughs we've had
here in the last two years we're doing
this at scale both at the federal level
and now it done at the state level and
that connectedness is key to being able
to drive and feed the machine learning
models you know I would love to have had
this in the emergency department we had
a patient will call her patient X who
used to come to our IDI and it took us
about 18 months to figure out she was
actually four different people and she
would come in dressed as four different
people different wigs different clothing
styles and she would get prescriptions
for Perks Demerol T threes etcetera and
sell them and she'd sell the scripts and
she was using the money to take care of
her kids her kids hadn't been signed up
to chip and so they weren't getting any
benefits and so this was how she was
earning money and it really took our EB
Docs kind of saying you know she looks
really similar to that girl I saw just a
few days ago but it took us about 18
months to connect the dots that she was
the same person and it you know and then
we had to track her effectively to say
look she might have different hair and
she might have different clothes but
have we had something like this we
wouldn't have had to spend 18 months
ultimately we were able to get her
associated with the care team that she
needed and with the case management that
she needed and and I think that
benefited her and her family greatly and
part of the tragedy of that story too is
if you look at her barriers for her and
her children she was eligible for many
many different zillio grams that's right
it just wasn't getting this wasn't
getting it yeah excellent I'd like to
just do a shout out to for our Google
partners on this and the Alliance we
have with them this is the December
Scientific American article I referenced
earlier if you're curious about this I'd
encourage you to take a look at that and
with that we're gonna bring Doug back up
and we were happy to share some details
with you on opioid 360 thanks Mira and
Shawn and I know for those of you on the
front end of this they were skeptical of
my explanation of the power of the
partnership between Deloitte and Google
I think now maybe you have a different
appreciation for what I mean talk about
powerful in order to you know bring our
our capabilities together transformative
looking at this widespread epidemic in
this problem in a very different manner
looking at it very holistically bringing
in things that I had never heard about
right before you know wait I was aware
of this solution things like HUD housing
credits and how rides you know and other
sort of intervention
other than simply medical can make a
difference in people's ability to
overcome the addiction and the
challenges that they face associated
with that very very problem some
situation so we pretty much burned
through our time here today so I
encourage you to do a couple of things
one scan scan in that bar code right
there it'll take you right to our
website on opioid 360 at that website
knowing is there are more information
around this solution you can also
schedule a demo if with our team if
you'd like to do that also please visit
our booth 13:03 right out on the
showcase floor there walk in look up
look for Deloitte you can't miss it
our teams they're doing demos as well
and can answer any questions you have
around the solution and and get more
information around that so I think with
that I know you know maybe we have one
more minute it's one thing that you know
when I'm talking to the booth and I got
a lot of questions from from people who
stopped by one thing that I get quite a
bit is can can we take this outside the
u.s. I mean does it work you know is
there similar availability of the
information in order to to bring it to
an international perspective yeah so the
short answer is yes were actually pretty
aggressively in conversations with other
countries on this Deloitte partners in
those other states and I'd say there's
actually two dimensions where there's a
lot of activity to expand this one is
internationally and the second is the
predictive models that sit on top of the
data can also apply to other health and
disease topics so think obesity 360
diabetes 360 there's actually about 50
different areas where we've developed
predictive models and - so we see opioid
360 as being the start of something that
really could be big okay and thank you
and one last question the final question
is it is this smoke and mirrors I mean
just showing us really cool stuff or is
it actually in use anywhere I mean is it
then no it's a well first of all many of
these technologies the Khan
there are many pieces that have come
together they've really matured here
just in the past couple of years and we
have two active States that are
implementing it now and we're talking to
many others so and I think it'll start
in the States we're already starting to
talk to some of the private private
firms in the health space terrific thank
you I'd like to thank Sean and Mira for
this very enlightening perspective
around this very challenging epidemic
and thank you all for for attending and
again
[Applause]
[Music]